est-ce qu'on ait écouté de partout on
qui va nous les français tous non non
non on écoute on n'écoute pas les
français on écoute les personnes qui
sont des personnes d'intérêt oui on sait
qui vous êtes président de la république
ouais ya kim et miss vrai que les
ministres
les ambassadeurs la première dame la
première dame madame la toisième dames
la 4e dame mais que c'était renoncer pas
castaldi
mais non mais non c'est vrai et donc
ouais et tout le monde est écouté il ya
aussi des personnalités qu'on arrive à
être écouté tous tous les gens qui
représentent les intérêts ça veut dire
que les gens qui sont soit qu'ils ont de
du pouvoir de l'argent ou d'une
influence
vous êtes effectivement volé aristo vous
sur ce plateau ou non
mais vous vous et écoutez
vous et écoutez au mois par toi services
non maintenant on va déjà maussade
bah oui j'écoute quand même oui puis les
amerloques parce que les amerloques
écoute le monde entier ça c'est sûr je
suis temps en temps celui ci qui
s'égaillent ici ce soir tombait coûteux
d'habitude à gaza n'a pas de
nom mais ils deviennent fous enfin payer
ces messieurs n'aiment pas qu'on sait
vraiment quoi je suis écouté non ouais
ouais ouais ouais
la france a regardé vous êtes tous les
soirs avec 2 millions en face de vous
vous êtes un brin florian énorme donc et
donc si jamais on veut par exemple si
poutine voulait faire vraiment un gros
coup et ont ils seraient venus ici avec
une grosse valise en vous proposant de
faire une émission positive sur lui au
lieu de ma vie tu es comment quelqu'un
qui va le critiquer
[Rires]
si jamais le propose a demandé une
grosse bourde khalil quand je mange pas
de ce pain-là alors dans le documentaire
on va en parler dans un sens voudrait
dire combien de personnes sont écoutées
en france après mme c'est fou ce qu'il
ya dans le documentaire on apprend tout
par i pul d'espions voilà il n'y a pas
que des rats dans la capitale ya aussi
des experts
avec ces deux aéroports c'est cette
grande gare des grands magasins des
quartiers historiques et touristiques
est plus surprenante des cimetières la
capitale française offre un terrain de
jeu idéal pour les agents secrets
étrangers chaque jour c'est invisible se
fondent dans notre quotidien
tout parisien a pu s'en apercevoir
être au milieu d'une opération de
renseignement dont un restaurant la
table à côté ou à deux tables de là et
parisiens vivent dans un monde de
l'espionnage sans le savoir souvent et
heureusement sans s'en apercevoir
oui ce qui m'a frappé dans le dos argué
c'est que vous êtes présenté comme un
agent illégal ça veut dire quoi il ya
des questions légaux et illégaux ouais
les lego c'est ce qui travaille
officiellement dans les ambassades et
d'autres représentations officielles et
les illégaux si c'est sur ce qui vous
convient marque jamais ces électrons
libres en fait les élections libres sur
les fausses identités souvent les deux
d'autres pays et c'est peu dire que vous
êtes sans contact officiel avec une
ambassade et si on venait à vous
démasquer l'ambassade n'irait vous
connaître c'est ça absolument alors il
dirait on ne connaît pas cette personne
c'est ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs dans
les années 60 quand aux états unis vous
avez entendu si vous avez regardé le
pont d'édition la ccsa donc l'ambassade
de russie dizaine de noms après ils ont
passé par ni les voies impénétrables
ils lui ont donné un avocat et ont
trouvé soi-disant à cousin et ce cousin
c'était mon général qui que j'ai connu
quand j'étais au service c'est pas votre
neveu pascal non
il a juste rêver nul et merci ben oui je
sais qu'ils sont tous à paris les
espions
non pas forcément mais en fait de
comment on peut reconnaître un espion
finition si vous reconnaissez un espion
c'est qu'il est foutu ah ouais bah oui
peut avoir un espion le retour de la
femme bien sûr ah ouais bah oui on y
sera un espace est quelqu'un qui se qui
se fond dans la masse ah ouais moi je
suis plus un espion parce que personne
tout le monde me reconnaît menacer sa
maman vous fondre dans la masse et on
pète célèbre espion au possible ah ouais
possible parce que là aussi c'est ce que
j'ai fait aussi parce que j'avais quand
même 14 ans la télévision je paraissais
à la télévision mais sa tournée en
ridicule quand j'étais à l'école de kgb
en rentrant vous donne à fond non et
donc moi j'étais je m'appelle jakov fak
auf pendant trois ans non non à l'école
à jacob delafon oui
et toute l'école regarder une fois par
semaine mon émission dans laquelle il y
avait mon voix non
il faut dès demain sacre anecdotes oui
il ya des luttes sont plus propices à
l'espionnage comme les hôtels par
exemple mais qui a beaucoup déçu âge
dans les hôtels histoire ici c'est plus
l'élu technique ouais ouais mais on fait
dans la capitale ils ont encore les plus
intéressantes et les organisations
internationales
l'unesco il de l'escaut alors on le sait
comment à votre avis à combien de
personnes en france qui sont écoutées en
france 47 millions ou il ya peut-être un
million qui est écouté ouais ouais quand
même parce que en fait ne vous
n'imaginez pas les gens qui sont
derrière les écouteurs qui écoute c'est
les machines qui écoute en fait tout est
enregistré mais après il ya les ja il ya
les algorithmes lee qui tombent les mots
clés et quand ils tombent les mots clés
là il se branche sur la conversation et
là il ya l'humain qui arrive derrière
les américains en fait c'est quoi les
mots clés comme sont les évitant les
mots clés bombe un espion kgb servier y
hanoune a
explosé juste est-ce que juste ils sont
payés par qui ces espions ça dépend ça
dépend la plupart du temps ce par les
gouvernements d'accord ouais ouais après
il ya des entreprises privées qui
peuvent se payer aussi des espions
après il ya des personnalités qui
peuvent avoir des espions ah oui la
plupart du temps c'est les gouvernements
oui j ai sergei vous expliquer par
exemple président de la république le
premier ministre des personnalités sont
écoutés oui elles le savent elles sont
pas plus bêtes donc ça veut dire que
sans doute se sachant écouter elles vont
balancer de fausses informations mené
par le contre espionnage pour tromper
les espions et demi c'est très
intelligent mais il croit en fait que y
possèdent des téléphones qui sont
protégés qui sont cryptés et que le
service les services français leur dise
c'est impossible de les de l'est
devaient pénétrer a été les américains
l'ont fait et snowden qu'il a raconté
s'ils nous donnent qu'elle a raconté il
a demandé l'asile au pays parce qu'il a
il a révélé ça on lui a dit noël en
miettes net il est parti chez poutine
mais ce n'était hélas quand même raconté
que chirac était sur écoute aunis aux
échos ces écoutes à un gala merkel tout
tire tous les dirigeants c'était sûr
qu'ils sont ce soir ils sont sur écoute
sur écoute par des partenaires d ali ben
salim parce que ses cousines les écoutes
c'est normal les iraniens les écoutes
c'est normal le fou ce sud nord quand on
les écoute c'est normal pas sachez que
vous êtes tous sur écoute
tout le monde s'écoute parsons écoutant
fait payer s'écoute alliés et ennemis
finalement personne n'apprend rien cc66
ici tout le monde sait qu'il ya les
machines qui qui qui savent trouver
l'information ils vont après ciblé
l'information vous coûter précisément
les conversations qui les intéresse
c'est fou ouais et puis il ya autre
chose aussi c'est que si la personne que
vous avez dans vos contacts et écoutez
vous et écoutez automatiquement
tony qui se trompe on se doit de tout ça
tu connaissais sergei de l'exclusion
louis blanc s'est dit sceptique - comme
quoi que les gens et que les les les
grandes nations écoute c'est normal de
tout en s'attachant à paris maintenant
et pour le mata hari et des espions y en
a toujours eu mais sergei je ne peux
poser une question et tu es un espion ou
triplex existe je ne serai pas espions
études et déjà on déteste le mois
espions je suis brian est ce que je suis
un officier de renseignement
un officier d'enseignement exactement et
ukraine pas tu te rends pas tout ce que
j'ai expliqué samia g 10 amis il me
protège là je suis là vous me protéger
la visibilité sans mais les dégâts
regardez les interviews j'ai déjà fait
acheter mon humour
à combien il est un livre
il est utilisé son incroyable qu'on a pu
voir décerner ce prix si l'église
orthodoxe russe n'est pas restée là
quelques pas de la tour eiffel elle se
trouve à côté d'une antenne de l'elysée
il y aurait des antennes dans le toit de
l'église qui capterait tout ce qui se
dit dans le bâtiment d'à côté c'est
incroyable isa se trouve
géographiquement à côté d'un bâtiment
qui est à sa droite qui est annexe de
l'elysée
vous avez des appartements des hauts
fonctionnaires qui travaillent autour du
président de la république des membres
du cabinet de l'état-major particulier
des manuels macron ayant accès à des
informations sensibles sont donc
logiques dans ce palais de l'alma qui
touche la cathédrale et le centre
culturel orthodoxe russe ayano dick le
contour de ces bulbes ne cache pas
d'antenne pourrait coûter entre autres
des jalles annexe de les équiper
évidemment que ça doit servir pour le
renseignement russe d'une façon ou d'une
autre c'est impossible que ce ne soit
pas le faire c'est incroyable c'est en
plus que dans le dock ce qui est
absolument génial c'est qu'on voit
vladimir poutine inauguré en mai 2010
cinq ans et serguei qu'en mai 2017
poutine a déjà tout dans la tête de ce
qui va faire aujourd'hui
c'était pas impossible parce qu'il avait
déjà en 2008
en 2008 quand elle a toqué géorgie il
avait déjà en tête plein le crâne ouais
d'accord donc c'est
on parle aussi des antennes sur le toit
de l'ambassade russe pendant des écoutes
sur elle-même des antennes donc sur le
toit ça aussi c'est complètement sain si
vous confirmez ça oui oui tout à fait
mal jaugé qu'on veut racontée dans un
documentaire je confirme donc en fait
aller les antennes il y en a plusieurs
d'abord et écoute tout ce qui est
sécurité à l'intérieur de paris parce
qu'elle compte quand les espions sur le
tir sur le terrain il faut assurer leur
sécurité ça veut dire nous avons des
techniciens à l'ambassade à l'antenne du
kgb qui commence à écouter la police les
pompiers etc pour savoir si ryad
d'anormal ne se produit s'il voit qu'il
ya un tout petit peu de plus de
conversation dans tel point maintenant
où on va il va se passer une opération
ils vont se dire tiens ils sont au
courant peut-être et live et ils vont
envoyer un signal on annuler l'opération
gouvernement français quand il apprend
qu'il ya potentiellement des antennes
dans l'église russe c'est ce qui l'a
doit de vérifier par exemple il n'a pas
le droit de vérifier parce que c'est le
territoire de l'ambassade de russie donc
c'est un ses couverts par l'immunité
diplomatique
et d'ailleurs il ya c'est un scandale
c'est dans cette église c'est un
scandale parce que la constitution russe
interdit fait la séparation entre
l'église et l'état et cette église a été
construite avec le budget de l'état
russe et me le maire de paris ni le
gouvernement français n'a jamais
interdit ça c'est une c'est un scandale
alors il ya un autre truc qui est
incroyable aussi c'est que l'ambassade
américaine située à seulement 500 mètres
de l'elysée et du ministère de
l'intérieur installer des bâches avec
des fausses fenêtres sur son toit pour
cacher son un centre d écoute c'est fou
ça et on peut rien faire ben non parce
que c'est ça leur a passé à ceux ci
d'ailleurs c'est ainsi un jeu assez
assez extraordinaire il ya une
convention de vienne de 1963 sur les
relations diplomatiques et consulaires
cette convention dit qu'on peut pas
utiliser les ambassades d'eau à d'autres
fins que à des fans diplomatique
maintenant toutes les ambassades vous
avez des services d'espionnage que tout
le monde sait que ce sont des services
d'espionnage tout le monde peut les
nommer le nôtre les américains et cetera
et cetera est une personne ne dit rien
donc à une 8,3 à paris 1 157 vous nous
écoutez par sarah après les petits pays
n'ont pas les moyens parce que l'espèce
ça coûte beaucoup hein alors comment on
fait pour devenir espion c'est la
question qu'on se pose minsk non moi je
peux postuler vous allez sur le site du
service d'espionnage qui vous intéresse
maintenant il ya une page vous voulez
peut vous voulez devenir espion postuler
pour un emploi vous remplissez le
formulaire et après quelqu'un va vous
contacter faire une enquête sur vous
vous passer des tests ici vous pouvez
aussi vous convenez avec moi les tests
ses coins et s ça dépend pour qui et
pour quel service que vous alliez vous
allez travailler parce que services
d'espionnage on peut vous prendre comme
secrétaire juste taper leurs actions pas
vous cyril
mais une personne oui ce que vous seriez
par vous avez été formé à booba par
exemple vous savez va partir dans bien
vous battre manier les armes tout ça ça
c'est ici un mythe en fait les espions
c'est l'éclair s'est pas desserrée clerc
de notaire en fait notre travail c'est
l'information non que l'information et
de la formation à nos gouvernements on
nous a appris la base là bas c'est à
dire que quand on rentre à l'école
d'espionnage ont fait trois semaines de
stage commando ça veut dire moi je suis
allé dans les divisions de toula de
parachutistes ont sauté avec un
parachute une fois juste pour savoir si
si si on a
donc il ya deux personnes qui n'ont qui
ont eu peur donc éliminé à larissa après
on vous apprend un tout petit peu les
bases de notre défense c'est pas
forcément la question parce que des fois
vous allez donner rendez vous à votre
source que vous avez recruté et avec
laquelle vous vous échanger des
documents qui se passe dans les
quartiers pourris et dont pour pour être
sûr que vous ne craignez pas forcément
enfin il faut être sûr de soi quoi oui
est ce qu'un espion peut être espionnés
parce que commanderait sur des policiers
des services assurés question bien sûr
nous avons notre service de sécurité à
l'intérieur de notre service nous avons
du service de contre et de
contre-espionnage extérieur et puis nous
avons les services a en face qui qui
veulent nous espionner donc tout le
monde est discuté à la limite c'est ça
sergei quand même dans le documentaire
on voyait des opérations armées il ya
des espions guéant qui tuent des gens
connaissaient le parapluie bulgare mon
poids zone et donc je suppose que parmi
les russes les techniciens russes les
légendes l'ambassade de russie fois
peut-être vous il ya des gens qui mènent
des opérations avec des armes pour
éliminer des rivaux
absolument mais en même temps il faut
bien comprendre que c'est ce sont les
exceptions le quotidien d'espions c'est
très chiant c'est les papiers les
papiers les papiers les papiers après il
peut y avoir des choses donc peut-être
actuellement puisque je passe déjà je
sais pas combien de fois ci sur votre
plateau vont se dire il nous casse les
les pieds et et on va peut-être
l'éliminer donc à peut-être une cellule
à l'ambassade de russie commence à
travailler sur sur moi et donc si jamais
ça se passe je compte sur vous pour me
faire un bel hommage oui un bel hommage
ce soir je serai dans la rubrique de sa
charge
il ya une petite question ouais
c'est ça l'accord cet espionnage
bah oui bien sûr et pourquoi
pourquoi on espionne la corse on
l'espérait la course parce que vous avez
un mouvement nationaliste qui fout la
merde en france et enfin entre
guillemets ainsi en fait on sent la
merde encore en corse en france oui mais
du court bon on vous espionne pour avoir
le pied aussi là dedans parce que si
jamais poutine veut par exemple créer
des quelque chose de mauvais de
détention dans le pays et il va
peut-être recoté quelqu'un encore s'il
va faire comme si c'étaient les corses
qui ont fait ça comme ça on vous fait
porter le chapeau et puis lui il est
très content en chine et alors il ya des
gens qui disent aussi que vous serez
encore espions et que vous viendriez
dans l'émission pour nous espionner bas
le tout c'est que en fait si je
crois que je dise
personne ne va croire c'est ce à quoi
que je dise ouais après le tout c'est il
ya des gens qui disent mais pourquoi il
est là pourquoi il nous raconte tout ça
pour quoi pourquoi les autres ne
viennent pas on a essayé depuis ce matin
avec votre homme bien sûr de trouver
parce que j'ai des amis espion français
on les a invités ils ont dit non on veut
pas prêt parce que eux ils ont la
l'obligation de réserve ils n'ont pas le
droit de le dire s'il lui disent ils
vont en taule d'accord moi je suis
protégé par mot statut de réfugié donc
j'ai lâché nos énormes chance de
raconter vous
de raconter tout ça et je suis quasiment
la seule personne en france à pouvoir le
faire